thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]
did you speak to anyone and meet anyone
yeah we did we said hello and they
welcome to Wales okay what is it like
having them here what did it mean I'm
really proud really proud
prince and princess the world definitely
why is that I just like the the
structure the order of it thank you
congratulations
um what does it mean having a visit like
this here oh amazing I have to admit
that we're on holiday but we're just a
stunned absolutely amazing did you get
to speak to either of them tell me what
tell me what tell me what we're saying
this is a good story
um my husband shot William's hand and at
the meantime my son was pulling my
husband's hair out and Lisa and William
said oh that's what happened to me so
yeah we'll never forget that it was and
I should pay tan so we're just we're in
shock and just amazing
does Wales need a prince of Wales uh I
think I think so yeah I agree yeah yeah
I agree
thank you guys very much thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
what was it like having them here it's
amazing it's nice to think that they
think enough of us to come and visit and
not only that they've circulated
everywhere they didn't just get out to
their car and get back in and they spoke
to everyone here just like normal people
it's so nice why do you think Wales
needs a prince and princess away because
we don't want a president there's a dead
switch Nobody Does it Like the UK Nobody
Does it like this
We're British first and foreign
to show the internet really it was
amazing yeah what about an investor
chair what do you reckon about having a
big an investiture not a big one no no
just a I don't think it would take a
couple that would appreciate a big
investor especially after all what's
gone partner
amazing as it was
um yeah just quietly just absorb into US
oh yes yeah we'd like to uh yeah we'd
like some sources because they are our
Crimson princess but not as Grand as
child said but then that was an effort
because
ladies thank you very much
how is that for you
all right